so returning to in-person learning
playing sports mental health
and gun safety were all on the agenda
last night for the ccsd school board
a lot of topics orca mana has more on
what was discussed
[Applause]
ccsd parents say it's just been too much
of this
distance learning and not enough of this
in-person activities
those were just some of the issues the
board of trustees tackled
we must return to in-person learning in
the safest way possible
as soon as possible nevada governor
steve sisolak kicking off thursday's
ccsd board meeting on everyone's minds
reopening schools
some parents questioning if their
students will be safe what is the
trajectory to have
every school have improved ventilation
other parents protesting outside ccsd
headquarters demanding school sports
return in addition to letting kids back
in the classroom
we have states across the country that
have pulled this off safely
we all need to get on the same page for
the sake throw these kids a lifeline for
pete's sake
board members also touched on student
suicides in clark county a topic that's
gotten national attention
students who died by suicide over the
past year it was the majority that
was caused by firearm the board
discussing a resolution that would
require
parents to sign an awareness letter as
part of student registration
acknowledging the safe storage of
firearms in the home it
is keeping students teachers and staff
safe from the threat of gun violence
but after a lengthy discussion trustees
decided to come back to it before june
1st
the only thing that parents want us to
be focused on right now is whether or
not their kids are going to be educated
in the building
sometime this year trustees also
approved a memorandum agreement to pay
school psychologists more to increase
recruitment and that's especially
important given the mental health
challenges
students have faced during the pandemic
reporting in the newsroom orca mana 8
news now